you are incapable of Defending a man
that you worked for that you know why
don't you ask me a question I did ask
you a question
and you said that you needed to hear
more from him well you just accused me
of something so why don't you let me
actually answer you're not gonna vote
for a pumpkin now I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna finish what I'm gonna say a
lot of people died because of how he
handled the covid crisis
yesterday
he also was a parrot for Trump
Sonny likes to make it personal for me
so we'll just he's well are you going to
give me a chance to speak in the truth
spearheading troop uh trumps
this is not what the show is about this
is Barbara Walters
okay like I can feel like a tumor
growing in my mind I have no sympathy
for Alyssa she's a very silly person
she's an intellectual lightweight and
she needs to act like a grown woman